and why is this so laughable down here
he's British but he's gonna rap yes I am
actually
I will take five topics and then we'll
drop a beat do a freestyle rap if you
sat in this section here they're kind of
Enclave what would you like a rap about
The Exorcist
wow yeah [__] great okay
it is
we've already had a suggestion from your
side and that's from six and a half
years ago this is those of you that
don't know or aren't you know
connoisseurs of memes it was the gorilla
that got killed and then the meme became
dicks out for harambe and uh yeah that's
it makes sense doesn't it The Exorcist
not harambe middle front of the room
what would you like a rap about
you said corgis and you said the forest
fire out from like a week and a half ago
yeah okay cool corgis and forest fires
were all combine them
back off the room so far corgis and
forest fires the axis what are you what
are you saying
Doctor Who that's a [__] suggestion I
[__] why do we even bother right
middle front of the room be better than
that
you said booty
okay yeah you love it red yeah
booty
this corner of the room hello
Ellis Island
fair enough yeah
Ellis Island The Exorcist corgis and and
the forest fires booty and then what are
you saying oh will is will have you got
something we're okay just so you know
this isn't like I don't say to will I'll
say something for the rap and we'll
prepare it he does this when I'm on
shows and it's always so [__] absurd
that please will tries to because I'm
really good at this right so he tries to
[__] me up every single time so go for
it will I can't wait
lion queefs
[__] first dicks out for harambe
now like okay lion queefs lion queefs
yeah how do you you felt good about
booty how did you feel about lion
queef's red
you like booty better that's the correct
answer well this this is a freestyle
that's a wrap made up on the spot based
and telling those suggestions the rap is
as good as a suggestion so this rap will
be about a 5.5 out of 10.
so let's make some magic and have some
fun
[Music]
[__] out just so you know I make the
wrap up they make the music up this is
this is entirely improvised and it's uh
it's gonna be delightful
we'll start the freestyle off I'll do my
duty see your big backside calling that
a booty I don't mean treasure Pirates
buried in the X Mark the Spot I just
mean the backside the derriere or the
bottom I see a lady who's got one that's
so big that it never be forgotten it's
fixed to my memory see it on my retina I
see the booty and I'm like yeah I'm
getting her and if I see red by my side
I'm like let's fight it out who can make
her the bride with the nice derriere two
cheeks so big she couldn't be killed my
whole thing for weeks so strange and
your friends disappeared she's like
booty no I'm out of here I find it
laughable that he could do a rhyme
airless Island immigration time you
would arrive there who's to blame if
you're polish you'd change your name
they say this is too many K's and Zeds
you need to switch it to something more
European instead the Statue of Liberty
mouth of the harbor coming over here
legally upper lava really the
anniversary but it's be hard it's taken
me six years to get a green card but now
I've got one did it legally I've got the
cash for lawyer so it's less equal C if
you get this and change it all around
the person at the back so quiet their
sound wasn't Amplified no decibel they
were shouting Doctor Who Doctor Who but
I couldn't get the yell ah he's a Time
Lord with the Tardis but it wasn't loud
enough so we can't start this bit and
what did this man say he was like a dead
gorilla throw me with harambe R.I.P for
the Jungle King I'm whipping out my knob
and I start helicoptering to celebrate
the guy who passed away spinning round
like the girl back in the day like the
head spinning round on the top of the
shoulders you gotta wait till you're 18
or older to see The Exorcist let it rip
vomit's spilling everywhere did the
whole spider [__] walking down the
stairs that'd be Linda Blair she's like
Let Jesus [__] you I am aware if you've
not seen this it comes across bad lead
directed Master for lead by William H
black tea they got the stairs they're in
that City Buckets of Blood it's really
not pretty to say the least you'll upset
the priest it's so violent what is these
horrible smoke all the smogs caused by
the dogs the corgis went to Canada and
did the job they've got a lot to care
about there in Ottawa in French Canada
they say it's hotter there burn down all
the trees why are we doing this we'll
try and put it out by lifting legs and
then piss dog spray Porgy what I mean
Canada teamed up because technically the
queen used to own it that's true though
covering the skyline shake your fist at
Trudeau why did you do this it's hard to
believe I went to the zoo and I heard a
lion queef came out of there what a nice
thing it was Nala from The Lion King ah
why is it coming the queef's out there
down there you're filling lion smells in
the air going round and really lay my
chest bare and she was creeping on her
friend Simba
[Applause]